this year is all about looking for the
bright spots because i mean we've been
going through so much
obviously and the hip hop awards are one
of those bright spots so what can you
tell us
about what we can expect oh yeah as far
as the um bt awards
my performance will be labeled as epic
okay on the head i had the director
brian barbour helped me put the vision
together
and um of course my my little bro lil
wayne and
it's uh a tribute to blackness i
consider it very rare for
you know me and him to do something like
this without it looking like we're
reaching or being preachy
um it has you know elements of
you know black excellence without giving
too much away you know
i don't even want people to you know put
it together in their head but
you know you know about a week or so
you'll be able to see
uh like i said a performance that i
consider that they'll label it
epic with me weighing and some other
things going on that we did some
tributes
you know obviously to the current
climate right
race relations so so is this going to be
virtual
or is this a live experience can you
tease anything about that
yeah i can tell you it's virtual i can't
take it
i i mean you know we're trying to adjust
to this whole you know
music right now you know i love to do it
you know in front of thousands but also
doing it virtually allows you to be
creative and do some other things to
bring to people
you know thousands or millions of people
whoever gonna view it so
um i can't tell you which one i actually
you know enjoy
best yet but i can tell you the one that
we just did the virtual one that we just
did for
for the bt performance i'm super elated
about i'm super excited
yeah you want me excited i can't wait to
see it well other than great music this
year's hip hop awards are about
motivating the black community to get
out and vote
so my question for you is what role do
you think
or how important of a role do you think
hip-hop plays in this year's election
hip-hop has played a huge role in voting
since you know you saw a puppy doing
boat or die
you know and 15 years ago
we underst we understand our voice we
understand our platform
we are you know saying we conscious of
our influence now we know when you say
culture you're talking about
us
we're just being specific now and we
know
how many people you know actually
you know we have more more followers
than any preacher in the world
and the biggest super church in the
world
man i got i don't know 8 9 10 million
followers
alright so once you realize your
influence
and you understand how to channel that
and what you need to do with
it i'm saying especially being a hip-hop
is not hard to do
am i gonna make a whole album telling
people to vote
now right it's definitely the bright
side of all these things that's been
going on when you're here
it's definitely the other side of the
pillar yeah
[Music]
you know i align myself up organically
with stuff that pertains to me let
fellas know you can vote
you just do your research letting the
youth know you can be better than what
you're doing if you live long enough if
you stay out of jail
you stay out the coffin you know i mean
it's just me you know i'm in i'm in a
really really good place right now
like not just financially but just man
spiritually you know what i'm saying
just
all together so you know
yeah that matters that makes a
difference you could tell too i want to
talk to you about building generational
wealth you spoke about how you're in a
really good place
and just do you have any message or if
you had
one key to give people in the black
community on how to
just start to build generational wealth
what would that be
faith save
save first
you know yeah a lot of the time
a lot of the times we do impulse
spending
you know when i was
when i was you know hustling doing what
i had to do i would go
i would put myself on punishment
sometimes right i wouldn't go to the
club
i wouldn't buy no clothes like no new
clothes i would just
stack my money up right and then when i
was over that time period
i would try to put it somewhere where i
can not be in that
same place that i was at when i had to
be conscious of what i did
every day and how it controlled my
eating and living and all of that right
so i was curious i literally went
through peers like you know the next 30
days man y'all can have that i'm
and then you know i'll get some money
and i'll you know i'll try to buy
something
that can make me more you know
right well and and and that's the same
thing with
with that's just starting off because in
order to build generational will
you got to start with a person you have
to start with somebody right
so particularly this is what i did
to you know like i keep putting money in
and keep putting money in and now i have
you know more businesses than i do
children
so now i figure out which kid gonna get
wet i mean i do
but it's not gonna be as hard as maybe
somebody else that just got one business
right i mean so now i do have i got more
business
and that's a bar i need to put that in
the song you should those technically
they're technically your children too
right that's hard
that's all yeah well you got to give me
credit on that one because i i sparked
the idea
that's funny okay i know i have like
probably two more seconds with you but i
just want to talk about the money maker
fund really quick because as a fellow
hbcu grad
i think it's what you're doing is
amazing what sparked this idea for you
to
invest in students businesses
um a a former hbcu student i'm a
businessman
i have a song called money maker which
is doing really well for not just me
but you know for everything around me
you know i'm saying everything is just
emotional for me to be work going on my
sixth album
and and i'm still dropping music that is
you know considered to not be at my peak
yet is a blessing so i'm in a position
to give back
and i just wanted to be creative so i
had these ideas for scholarships and
everything but
you know if i just you know think about
it i'm talking i'll be talking about
llc's i'll be just trying to preach
but that's good because a lot of people
they want it but they don't know the
tiny steps that take to that it takes to
having that
that yeah and
and and that's what i'm saying like this
so with the money maker phone we have
people send
if they currently have a business up and
running though you know what i'm saying
it just needed
a little push just so you know what i
mean
it may be up and running and doing good
you know what i mean but we're going
through
to get 10 uh you know ideas that i
feel like because because it's important
for me to find an idea that everybody
else thinks
thinks is funny too or doesn't make
sense you know right
that's a smart business man and it's
innovative too
and with this maker fund i get it's
nothing that fine print
i want nothing out of the deal this is
truly you know straight from the heart
i'm just trying to help somebody out if
it
pans out you know if they can come back
and
pull me whatever you know what i mean if
god bless them but
what i'm contributing it won't i won't
lose sleep about it
you